by popular demand its Mars Needs Moms
yeah sorry it took so long to get to
these we've kind of been busy with a few
other things but here I am and I finally
saw one of Disney's biggest
disappointments the critical and
box-office flop that actually destroyed
Robert Zemeckis a--'s motion capture
company yep remember Polar Express
Beowulf Christmas Carol you're gonna see
nothing like that anymore because this
is the film that killed it some would
say that's a shame others would say
thank God because of the KITT turning
out films like this yeah it's not a big
loss the film was about a little boy
who's having trouble getting along with
his mother only to discover she's being
kidnapped by aliens and he follows along
they're taken to a planet that's ruled
by females who have absolutely no idea
how to take care of children huh
then how did they survive all these
years okay we'll get all that the boy
comes across another guy who is taken
hostage long ago and while he doesn't
like what they do he just sort of learns
to accept it because he has no other
choice but the boy says he does have a
choice and thus the two of them as well
as an alien graffiti artist decide to
change how Mars works fight the evil
repressive system and stop all the
mothers from being destroyed oh yeah
when the mothers not use their
usefulness they just blow them up and
that gets to kind of a major problem of
this movie okay I know they always say
don't judge a movie by its title but the
title of this movie is Mars Needs Moms
okay it's stupid it's one of the worst
titles for a movie ever but at least
when you hear it you get an idea what
you're going to get something playful
something goofy and colorful kind of
light-hearted but no this is a really
dark miserable-looking even intense film
this is humor while the characters talks
about seeing his mother actually get
destroyed right in front of his eyes and
it's told really slowly and really
dramatically and all I can think to
myself is Mars Needs Moms but no one
really matter if the film was say
creative or charming or imaginative and
it's surprisingly not I know the idea of
this world is that supposed to be
repressive and there isn't any color but
come on even for a repressive world
we've seen this a million times
it looks like Tron it looks like 1984 it
looks like The Matrix it looks like all
these movies we've seen with miserable
world of the jillion times and it's just
not interesting anymore I guess the idea
of a race run by females and all the
males are just kind of left in the
garbage is kind of interesting but even
then I'm not really sure what kind of
commentary they're trying to get across
if any is this like a wicker man remake
is women taking over a good thing or a
bad thing or this is supposed to show
ironically how like how men treat women
or women treat matter I don't know maybe
there is no commentary maybe it's just
the way this planet does things and they
just need an enemy to go after and
that's exactly what this film feels like
it feels like everything is there just
so it can kind of be there a kid travels
to Mars because kids want to travel to
Mars they fight oppressive systems
because kids like fighting oppressive
systems Hey look how much they argue
with their parents we're gonna motion
capture Seth Green as the little kid
even though he doesn't do any of the
voice because we just kind of motion
capture celebrities for some reason at
least with Tom Hanks and Jim Carrey they
were in the movie they got to use their
voices but Seth Green I mean he's a fine
actor but did you absolutely need this
guy in this role I can tell you that his
addition doesn't add anything nor any of
the characters John Cusack she's one of
my favorite actresses she is so funny
and so entertaining yet she's just there
to kind of be there for Phil about Kuta
wants to go save his mother they don't
make this mother interesting at all and
it's such a shame to hear someone I know
is so uniquely fun like John Cusack just
given nothing to work with so I guess if
you're just in a mood to save fight the
power and the repressive whatever zazz
hey those films do well sometimes this
one definitely doesn't make any sense
but I guess if you just want to get that
rebellious emotion out of your system
but I'll side from that I have no idea
who would enjoy this film it's not the
worst it's just dull and when it's not
dull it's kind of unpleasant and for a
movie called Mars Needs Moms you
wouldn't expect something so grim and
depressing in terms of at least seeing a
yearly film with motion capture that's
going to look like a really high budget
production they're pretty much extinct
now
and it's hard to say this is a good
thing or a bad thing but there are
anything like this film I can say we
definitely trade it up